Scot Neil said yesterday he loves his
complete level this year here's Morris
he shoots it that's off the stick and high
and that actually did go over the glass first
round pick way back in 2016 the 12th overall
selection Peretti carries it over the line
heer's quick feed nikov looking for Peretti
want a save by Smith three defense from the
Jets they get out of trouble there and how
about this fantastic execution all three guys
the centering pass Conor best chance
of the game right there for Winnipeg
Conor to the corner centers it that
goes all the way back to morisy he'll
move it to a Circ in corner on
the move of the shot C [Music]
St Kyle Conor would not be denied and the
Jets have struck first this one just goes
off the crossbar and the Jets Coral the pock
back and look how quick KY Conor turns out
of the corner and gets a quick release keeps
his speed in the rebound you guess it right
back onto his four hat inadvertently by peret
Samberg has to be careful holla took it away
Eric Halla finding Lazar walked in he lost the
handle he it a little to tight and hold set a
hold of him appon knew that uh neita Ryder was
moving great pass from Lowry to Ron running it
off the iron he had all day to walk in what
a setup from Adam Lowry for forc coner touch
to a better Angle now finding Mory as they move
around onner C FL here's P for fny S it through
[Applause] [Music] he I don't think pery
originally got the shot he wanted but he
beat the goenda wiip look at the motion from all
Five Guys you got shley by the post and he's up
in high ice again and you've got guys pulling
the penalty kill out out of structure and there
it is you look and you wait for a seam that's why
you possess the puck and you move the seams there
Peretti probably doesn't get the shot off that
he wants but it's enough to such a crafty player
Pat took his pass he's given a cushion Hughes BR
back for poot good pass with the sloly score Meyer
pulled the trigger a devil's power play goal and
it's two to [Music] one no real dangerous plays
given up but that's again why you hold the puck
look at the ENT Exchange in high ice a little
Dro pass okay that shifts the penalty kill just
enough and there isn't much time but just enough
for team o Meer to get that shot away and who
stick does that hit right there Dylan samber in
that well travel Eric M from the knee got a man
out front it was Tierney but was unable to get
the puck now tney finds it kicked that by Conor
Luke Hughes again shoots off the rebound a good
stop and another one they score couple of loose
pucks finally cleaned up by the defenseman Marino
is first of the year has his tie of two Devils
are able to extend the shift after scoring on
the power play they seem to come out with a burst
of energy and right there you grind it out of the
corner three guys win that battle and now again
you get your defense ch facing a shot often turns
into two turns into three and that's a tough one
as the double skate downhill on that rebound and
huk does his job twice didn't have any angle
to put it in but he tried hit the side of the
net just under two left now in the second back it
comes to S time for Peretti here's a feed and eer
[Applause] scores Nikolai elers on a brilliant
feed from Cole Peretti and the Jets lead it
again [Applause] at the net to start this play
you look at the Puck Stop in the corner so by
committee you dig it out and then it's going to
be Peretti that's going to go to the net earlier
and he gets the first touch really nice passes
he gets it back in the slot everybody's thinking
that second of the season for him as he picks
it up production wise gets looking for another
one not TI just wide by Appleton Jason Appleton
treding to steer it up front theer rer the blue
paint they crack away at it off the wall and what
opens up it's the seams and this is the same thing
you follow it up with a back to- back grind shift
look at that the price you pay the hunger you have
to have to score and getting ahead of myself a
goal and an assist as Marino lets it go back from
a file behind the net it goes toley to brat shov
there by morisy toley quick shot he's always had
a good release you know what at the age of 31 he
has his clear High last year in goals 34 of them
assist he's aging like Wy Here Comes Adam Lowry
off the rush shot rebound and made the sa onita
Rider shley reached out for it bouncing Puck
te there by douggy Hamilton now 30 years old
here's a chance for lazari centered it and hell
up with a big safe on H and he made another one
right there third time and before that you talk
about a a gamechanging save that's as good as a
goal the other way as hella Buck clearing attempt
that didn't work this time they get it out you
know Neer Rider looking to turn the corner on
Hughes Neer rer with the power move out front
swinging to miss by Aon but that's a strong
maneuver who will come away with this butt
will it be frozen devils are okay they would be
okay with that nice move by perti conter and he
R it hit the crossb from in that tight in any way
from range on the forehand and off the backhand
look at that I mean look at the amount of time or
the lack that thereof as he pulls it through the
Stick of Mercer to the backand Neer Rider from a
sharp angle back to pee off with the drive stick
save loose p thetic c caught about the shot he'll
reset P rer right through and stopped and held by
smid back hand goals already this season and he's
within a hair of doing it again and nice little
lookoff fake for pan to put an Excell she taller
BW a tire I follow picks up that loose butt Mory
took the pass pressure from holla but he kept it
in anyway that hit the there's a shot and they
store and it's Corner [Applause] again and what
a pass from shley 42 trust me when I say there's
nothing like seeing that in person look at that
brilliant and I mean brilliant pass for Mark shley
eyes on the back of his head and there's some
scheme on that right in the strike zone for Kyle
Conor and whap into the back of the neet no icing
says the linesman Soul ball will have to quickly
domov knock him down letnov sets it up the store
Baron with the shot another jets go and it's 5
two well you got Nikolai eers fighting Brendan
Smith they get the fourth goal and then you got
the much undersized lad the micov and he finishes
a check against a much bigger Dem man and taboot
he makes a beautiful play out to Morgan bar Holtz
took it from Mercer Hamilton paa shot block sber
where we seen that before Hamilton hit the goal
post and they score Mercer had a couple of cracks
at it he was able to settle it put it past eluk
and it's 5-3 tried to get a clear here and where
have we seen that before well we saw nine of them
two games ago nine block shots from Samberg and
that he sells out to block the shot and and
high iceis domov trying to do the same thing
but the puck clears his knee what a shot from
douge Hamilton off the cross bar that hit the
body of McLoud Puck is loose Appleton finding
Nikolai elers there three JS elers with it the
to of the game forers and that'll put
this one to bed 63 WI a peg right there
just in the right place a heavy stick
to win a battle separate the man from
the puck and then he just distributes It Wide
to eers eers is thinking past this entire way
but Lowry does a good job and it was tied to
two and then they turned it on from there the
fans appreciate what they've seen here tonight
the Jets take it 63 and it's all [Music] over